[Music]
andrew is in atlanta hi andrew how are
you
well gentlemen pleasure to speak with
you you too what's up um
so i have of course i was just recently
informed by the all-knowing government
that my student loans are being
transferred to naviance
and
given the questionable nature of that
company i'm wondering if that changes my
debt snowball the student loans are
nineteen thousand dollars they're
currently fourth in line in my debt
snowball
and uh i estimate being fully debt free
in uh the spring of 2023.
okay what's in front of it
uh two credit cards
and a land contract
which i also wonder if the land contract
carries more risk given something you
said recently yeah
yeah
so the land contracts almost paid out
it's not much
it'll it'll actually it yeah it actually
is probably number two
yeah um it's actually hard for me to get
my head around not doing so what is the
what is number
the student loans are number four what
is number three
number three would be a credit card yeah
what's the balance what's the balance
11 000. okay and what's your household
income
110
okay
so the stuff after the student loan is
what's dragging you out into 23 not
before
correct because you're going to be
busted you've got to be busting through
these four making 110 fast right george
yeah yeah i mean as far as navigators
i'm making some changes yeah naviance
sucks but they all do yeah i don't think
you have any worries there i wouldn't
adjust the snowball because of that no
um especially with your income
you i'd get these credit cards out of
them i was just concerned about
you know from our future and you know
they're they're they're all banned
that's wrong
naviant is just one we featured in
borrowed future but they all suck
and you know what it'll probably be
transferred again before you pay them
off and so that's just the nature of
that industry so i wouldn't be worried
about them screwing you over i mean it
doesn't whoever it's sitting with in the
student loan world is they're not as
much crooked as they are just
incompetent
which is actually worse because crooked
you can actually catch
incompetence you can't fix
and so you just have to manage you have
to watch your account and make sure
they're posting stuff the way they're
supposed to all the time anyway
whoever it is so just watch it like a
hawk and keep it right there's what i
would do yeah i don't see any need to to
move it around in the debt snowball i
think you just stay the course and use
this income to your advantage and maybe
try to increase it if you can to speed
this thing up because we're talking
you're done with the student loan though
in
what six months
yeah i'm probably done with it and um
by the end of 22. i've got a whole
spreadsheet of tracks yeah i think
that's a little late i think you need to
turn your fingers snowball up a little
bit because not 30 000 is the last two i
don't know what the first two are but
making 110 you need to get there i mean
yeah you need to get there inside of six
months yeah i don't want to keep these
things around like a pet but but that
that's a that's a different subject but
no i wouldn't move it to answer your
question i would watch them like a hawk
but any of you that have a student loan
you need to watch them all like a hawk
because they just can't find their butt
with both hands i mean they really are
incompetent they're just not i mean and
don't care
and they don't care they just do what i
mean they just lie yeah with every
payment i'm going to be checking the
website making sure they took out
exactly what needed to be taken out and
know more and watching that thing
constantly auditing your own account
yeah that's what you've got to do with
these people oh the navient people were
just it's just a poo
so